so you guys think just because she's the
host she can be disrespectful to people
no in a way yeah well no no yeah she can
be and then at that point you can either
leave or you yeah yeah because they're
chill you're like in their Kingdom it's
like their world you know you know what
it is because you know what Poe is
because you are the host of a podcast
you can be disrespectful to people sorry
where does that make sense it makes
sense that's how it's like it's like if
you're in somebody else's house they can
be disrespected to you it's like what's
that word you're not gonna oh yeah your
boss at work yeah if you're going to
somebody else's house and they're like I
don't want you to do it invite me to
your show I want some beans and she's
welcome to her I just said Pearl please
can you stop doing this whole
um you need to learn to listen it's
quite patronizing that's all I said what
was that being disrespectful yeah I
don't think that was the problem I think
it was trying to talk over her for over
and over and over here